FOUTSE KHOMH: So
I'm Foutse Khomh,
from [INAUDIBLE]
Montreal and it's
my honor to introduce to you our
second keynote speaker, Dinah
McNutt, from Google.
Dinah have been Release
Engineer for more than 20 years.
She ship all kind of
unit base software.
She contribute to a lot of
tech magazine of our Release
Engineering and she's
currently sharing
a couple of events on
Release Engineering.
So she'll be sharing
with us today
her ten commandments
on Release Engineering.
So please join me
to welcome Dinah.
DINAH MCNUTT: My
background is I have
a Masters in mechanical
engineering from MIT.
Somewhere along the
way, I discovered
system administration.
That was my passion
for years and years,
and then I discovered
release engineering.
And so I'm lucky actually
to be on my second career
and very delighted to be
part of this workshop today.
So one of the questions is,
what is Release Engineering?
I defined Release Engineering
as accelerating the path
from development to operations.
That's really what
our goal is, and what
our role is in our organizations
and in the industry.
I've given this talk twice
before, the first time was
four years ago at the
Usenix Lisa conference.
And I targeted it to
system administrators.
And basically, the
message was, here's
what you system
administrators need
to be asking the people
delivering software to you.
Here are the commandments you
need to ask them to live by.
And then I gave
it again last year
to a test automation group.
And there again the
message was, as testers
this is what you need to be
asking the people delivering
software to you.
So I'm actually excited
to be able to give
this talk to Release
Engineers, and I'm
going to be interested
in your feedback
on-- I think each of
us could get up here,
and there'll be some
overlap in our commandments,
but they will be
different commandments.
We could probably have
a hundred commandments
that we think we
need to be living by.
So I'm really going to be
interested in your alls'
feedback, and there should
be time for discussion
at the end of my talk.
So this is my talk, so we get
to talk about my commandments.
It's based on my years
of 20 plus experience
in developing
commercial software.
These concepts are not just
for web apps, or customer
facing software.
In a company like Google, I work
mostly with internal customers.
Almost nothing I
work on is external
facing because I work in our
infrastructure organization.
So there's lots of different
types of product delivery,
and lots of different
types of customers.
But I think these
commandments are applicable
regardless of what
your deployment method
or your customers.
And of course, the gratuitous,
these are my ideas,
not Google's.
So all of us, we're
Release Engineers, right?
Release processes are very
often an afterthought.
Organizations do them
because they have to
or because they've run into
problems and they're like gee,
if we had some process in
place, we could fix this.
It's been rare-- I think I've
only gone into one company
where I was hired on early
as a Release Engineer.
It was often very much,
much further down the path,
there was a lot
of rework that had
to be done to put
processes in place.
Most systems in companies
do just the minimum
to get it done.
You're so focused, so developer
oriented, and code oriented,
that the processes themselves,
they're after thoughts.
They're like, what do we have
to do to get this delivered
instead of stepping
back and saying,
how can we do this
better and how can we
use this to actually help our
whole development environment.
There's often a
disconnect-- and I
think we actually saw this
in an earlier talk-- where
the person who writes the
code, the person who tests it,
and the person who installs
it aren't communicating end
to end.
I think there was one
organization, where
they actually--
sorry, he said it
was Facebook-- sit in
with the developers,
and so they have very tightly
coupled communication.
And then other
organizations, maybe they
don't talk to each other
and there's go betweens.
This is a release process.
It's pretty simple, right?
You check out your code,
you compile it, you test it,
and you release it,
we're done, right?
It looks more like this, right?
We've got unit tests,
we've got packaging,
we've got system tests,
we're going to canary,
we've got more
system tests, we've
got bug fixes that
feedback into and causes
to start all over again.
And we deploy it.
Well this is what release
boxes really look like.
They're very complicated.
You've got build artifacts,
you've got report,
you've got all your tests.
And you really
need to understand
what's happening
in the end, and be
able to make the
decision like somebody
was talking about earlier.
Do we want to release this?
Is this a good change?
What information
do I have in order
to be able to make
that decision?
And so this is what makes
our job so interesting.
It's really trying
to solve, this
is one of the problems
we're trying to solve.
So here's my first
commandment-- thou shalt
use a source code
control system.
We've come a long way with
source code control systems,
I used SCCS and RCS, and
the whole gamut of Unix
based source code systems.
Thank goodness we have
things like Get Now.
I thought CVS of so
much better right.
And that SVN, oh my God, this
is so much better than CVS.
And now we have Get.
I can't wait to see
what's coming next.
And so we must use a source
code repository system.
What do we use it for?
Everything you need
to release should
be under some kind of
source code management.
This includes your source files,
this is the obvious thing.
This is the first
thing that comes
to mind when we talk about
source code management, right?
It is our code, our C
files, our Java files.
The build files associated
with building a software
are build tools themselves,
because the build
tools are going to change as
the environment changes right.
So you need to be tracking
that documentation even.
You're going to [INAUDIBLE]
your documentation
with specific releases, if you
have customer documentation.
And it doesn't matter which one
you use, just use something.
Related to this, and
one of the motivations,
is you want to have a
reproducible build environment.
One of my very first experiences
with release management,
release engineering, I was
actually Release Manager
at Tivoli back in
the early days.
My job was to work with-- I was
professional services person,
but we didn't have
any customers.
So it's like, well, while we're
waiting to have some customers,
why don't you perform this role?
And we had a release that
we could not reproduce.
We didn't have the build tools
in place that we can actually
go back to our source
code repository
and rebuild what we had
shipped to our customers.
So that was a lesson I took
away with me from many years
ago is you want to be
able to reproduce what you
were shipping to your customers.
You want to be able to
go back and patch it,
you want to be
able to support it,
you don't want to be a
position where you're
forced to roll
forward because you
can't support what they have.
So the operating
system, if you're
web-based or doing
managed hosting,
you've got to-- and even
your build environment.
You want to be able to reproduce
your build environment,
and part of that is
the operating system.
Your compilers,
your build tools,
the whole environment
needs to be recreated.
And maybe not all
of these things
that are in your source
code management system.
But maybe you have
configuration files
that are in the source
code management system,
so that you can actually get a
manifest of everything that's
needed, and all the
dependencies in order
to reproduce your
build environment.
Lots of solutions.
You can have backups
of your environments,
you can have
installation servers,
you can have virtual machines.
And so these are all solutions
that may not necessarily
be checked in to your
source code repository.
But you need to be
thinking of that.
Tie into this
configuration management.
I think it's going to be
interesting to see what happens
with configuration management
and Release Engineering,
over the next few years.
Configuration management
as a discipline
has been around much longer.
But I think these two
disciplines are actually
going to emerge and
evolve together,
because I don't see how
you could separate them.
And so related to
configuration management,
binary dependencies, your
configuration files, manifest,
change lists, machines
configurations.
Everywhere from your
dev environment,
to your testing environment,
to your deployment empowerment,
you need to be able to
understand what they are,
so that you can
troubleshoot problems.
OK, what about binaries?
My personal opinion
is that binaries
don't belong in an SCM.
However, that's not
a hard and fast rule.
We certainly at
Google, we have lots
of binaries in our
source code repositories.
But I think it's important
to be able to recreate
those binaries, and I'd like
to focus on everything that's
needed to actually
create those binaries.
And if you can do that
and its reproducible,
then why do you need
to store the binaries
if you have to put them
in a separate repository?
A source code
repository is really--
most of them are text
based, they assume texts.
And so something like diffing
on a binary file [INAUDIBLE]
isn't necessarily as meaningful.
John's agreeing with me.
OK, so the moral of this
is reproducibility ability
is a virtue.
You want to be able to
reproduce what you have.
That doesn't mean
you can necessarily
support what you have
out in a field maybe.
Maybe there's a bug,
and the only solution
is to roll forward.
But at least you understand
that and you understand
why the reason is,
apposed to, oh gee,
we can't recreate
that let's push out
a new version real quick.
The second commandment
is-- thou shalt
use the right tools for the job.
Just because you know a
programming language, doesn't
mean it's the right
tool for the job.
As software engineers, we
should be using the right tool
in choosing the right tool.
In Google, Go is
the new hotness.
And it's fun to
use Go, and there's
a lot of powerful things
you can do with Go.
That doesn't mean it's
the right solution.
Complex projects, you're
going to have multiple tools.
You're not going to
have just one tool.
The days of just having Make,
thank goodness, are over.
And we've got lots
of different tools.
And this is just a
very small subset
and obviously, there's lots of
commercial products available,
and open source
products available.
But I think it's a given, you're
going to have a mix of tools.
And when I'm talking about
tools here obviously,
I'm talking about
the low level stuff.
I'm talking about, your
compilers, your interpreters,
everything that
basically takes the bits
and turns them
into something that
can be run as an application.
I figure, one of
these days, I'll
be able to respond to ads,
looking for a Make person.
Because people will have
these Make files and nobody
at the organization
knows how to use Make.
Like COBOL programmers
in the '90s,
people were looking
for COBOL programmers.
Yes exactly.
Y2K was coming
around so I'm going
to make my fortune writing
Make files someday.
I hope not.
So the moral here is
unnecessary complexity is a sin.
So just because you know how
to use five different languages
doesn't mean you have
to use them all at once.
But there again, what we're
doing is complex by nature,
by definition.
So don't make it more
complex, than it really is.
OK the third commandment.
This is one of my favorites.
Thou shalt write portable and
low maintenance build files.
Someone talked about homogeneity
earlier and said by definition
that they were running
heterogeneously
on their front end machines.
So if you plan to support
multiple architectures in OS's
up front, even if
you never do, you're
job's going to be so much
easier, when you probably
will down the road.
So if you design this up
front and think about it,
how do you do this when you
have output for your compilers?
How do you want to
structure your trees,
how do you want
to name them, how
do you want to
name your packages?
I'm going to talk about
packaging in a little bit.
So this is something
that you really,
if you think about
this up front,
it will save you so--
how many people front
end to this, where you get down
the road and your like, oh gee,
we're dealing with
some of this in Google
right now to in some areas.
I think some people are lying,
I think I saw three hands.
Centralized configuration
files can really
save you a lot of time.
Centralized compiler
flags, configuration flags,
because I work at a start up
company where it's like, oh
gee, we want to change that
flag because we're supporting
multiple architectures
and I'm like,
no I really don't want to
edit all these build files.
And so it's time to have a
centralized build file and make
it configurable so that, you
don't have to go do that again.
One of the reasons you
want to do this is I
view part of my job as making
the developer's job easy.
Most developers really
don't care about build
files or packaging or
anything like that.
They really care about their
code and their cool code
and finishing it.
And so there's a lot we can
do through best practice--
and I'm going talk about
this a little bit more--
but through best
practices, to setting up
templates, and telling them.
You could do it in the,
guys, I'm helping you.
Or you're really
helping yourself,
because it means they're going
to be doing things the way
you want them to do instead
of having to retrofit or have
to go back later, and try to
convince them that maybe we
want to build with some
different build options,
because it's going to work
better in the production
environment.
And so this is where
I see us having
a huge role in
our organizations.
Related to this is build IDs.
And by the way we
structure or build files
and our build system,
we can have build IDs,
so that our builds can
be uniquely identified
and reproduced.
And this goes back to
the earlier commandment
of being able to reproduce
what it is we have done.
Here's some examples.
The big thing is you want
to be able to identify what
it is you have,
whether it's a binary,
whether it's a Debian package.
What is this, and
where did it come from?
Because if you can't
answer that question,
you're going to
have problems being
able to provide support
to your customers.
You can also embed
them in binaries.
Every knows if you type
command dash version,
and you can find out
what version it is.
And that information
needs to make it clear
based on your build system
and the tools you're using,
what that is, and
uniquely identify it.
So I have two morals
for this commandment.
Measure twice, cut once.
In other words, plan upfront.
Spend time working on templates
and consistent build files.
And then that way,
you don't have
to go back and rework later.
And knowing your
ancestry as a virgin,
if you're a binary
where did you come from.
Fourth commandment--
this conference
has really talked
about this a lot.
Thou shalt use a
release process that
is reproducible,
unattended, and automated.
And this is where CI comes in.
You should have a
continuous build process.
Maybe you have a
long release cycle
because you're shipping a
network appliance maybe.
There have been studies on
the sooner you detect a bug,
the cheaper it is
to fix that bug.
And so if you have a
CI process in place,
you can identify bugs
much, much sooner,
and fix them before they get too
far down your release pipeline.
So I think this is
important regardless
of what your
deployment process is.
And I actually don't talk a
lot about continuous deployment
in this talk, because I think
these four commandments apply
regardless of your
deployment process.
There's lots of tools
available, thank goodness.
This wasn't true 10 years ago.
Well I guess it was, I was using
cruise control 10 years ago.
You could write your own.
Or better yet, write plug-ins
for the existing ones
and open source them.
This is one of my
favorite topics
is Release Engineering
as a service.
And I'm actually going to
be doing a project on this
within Google this
year, this quarter.
Developers should be able to
operate in self service mode.
They should be able
to do their own bills,
and decide when
they're ready to deploy
what it is they have done.
We should work with them on
implementing and configuring
tools and policies
to help them do that.
We need to be defining what
the best practices are.
We need to have tools that
help us implement those best
practices.
It's important to
have workflows that
are reproducible
and predictable.
So that if one developer
does a release,
you get the same results as if
another developer does them.
So there shouldn't
be any guesswork.
You take the burden off of
them, they click a button,
and it just happens.
There again, you're
offloading the things
they don't like to do,
but empowering them,
which they very
much do you like.
They like being in
control of their code.
They know their code
better than we do.
But there again, all through
the release pipeline,
you've got to have
the tools in place
to help people make
the right decisions.
And one of the prelunch time
talks was talking about that.
How do you make these decisions
and how do you have the data?
And if it's a very,
very hard problem.
And I think this is where
Release Engineers can offer
significant value to
the organizations.
I know with-- I work in our
technical infrastructure--
and we save developers literally
hundreds of hours a year
because we can just tell
them, oh, here here's
what you need to do.
And they're like,
oh thank you, I
don't have to worry
about that now.
And they're very
appreciative, and it
makes the organization as a
whole much more productive.
All right, my second
favorite-- well actually I
guess it's tied for my
favorite commandment.
Thou shalt use a
package manager.
I love package managers,
I don't know why.
I've worked with a lot of
different package managers
over the years and dealt
with packaging problems.
And there are many
reasons why you
want to use a package manager.
You get auditing.
You can find out exactly
what is it a package.
When you install a
package on a machine,
depending want
package you're using,
you get different auditing
capabilities on this binary.
Where did this binary come from?
What package is it
associated with?
Many package managers
have hooks in place
for doing upgrades,
installations, removals,
and you can leverage that
instead of writing your own.
You can find out who
built the package,
when was it built, what
code base did it come from?
You get built in
version tracking,
independency checking.
What are some of
the other packages
this package depends on
before you install it.
What versions of those
packages were supported or not
supported.
Manifest.
What's in the package?
And I'm a firm believer
in using native package
managers where possible.
Course this is Google, we
have our own package manager.
Because of our infrastructure
and it's so complicated and so
Google centric, we tend to
write a lot of our own tools.
But we use Debian
packages, and we also
use our proprietary
Midas package manager.
And if you're
interested in that,
I did a talk on that
at UCMS last June.
But based on whatever operating
system [INAUDIBLE] RPM,
Debian package, Solaris
package manager.
It's OK to support all of those
different package managers.
So tar is not a package manager.
Really, and you can
replace that with jar.
I'm sorry, it's not
a package manager.
And I don't think it's OK
to tar up a bunch of files
and put them in
a package either,
because now you lose the
manifest capabilities
and the ability to query the
package, it's going to say,
I have this tar file
and you're like, OK
but what's in the tar file?
OK this is another commandment
that I learned the hard way.
You need to think about
your upgrade process
before-- I love it when
people nod, they're
like yeah I did that-- before
you release your first version,
think about your
upgrade process.
How are you going to upgrade?
Can you upgrade in [INAUDIBLE]?
If you have a
running binary, how
are you going to bring up a new
job and shut down the old job?
You had configuration
files that may
be customized by the
customer, that you
need to save off and replace.
Are there database
schema issues?
You're going to have to
have an upgrade there.
You've got to think
about that before you
do your first release.
Otherwise, you can paint
yourself into a corner
and have problems
doing your upgrade.
And this also will help
drive some of your packaging
decisions on how and what you
package in to your package.
So you have to think about, do
I have any pre-install commands
I need to run?
Do I have any post install
commands I need to run?
And a lot of package managers
have really good support
for doing this, but only if
you think about it and plan.
And related to that, think
down the road beyond just 1.0,
right?
You need to think about,
OK, can I roll back?
What happens if we,
particularly if you're
running in a hosted environment?
And I think somebody
talked about earlier
that they had a problem where
they couldn't roll back.
You want to be
able to roll back.
And may be rolling back
means you roll forward.
But basically, you're like,
OK, we have a problem,
we have to fix, how
am I going to do that?
If you're doing things like the
Debians and RPMs and so forth,
and those people are installing
the packages themselves,
they should be relocatable.
I should, as a
system administrator,
I should be able to decide
where I want the package to go.
Is anybody here shipping
software directly to customers?
There's a few hands.
Beyond the mobile.
I think obviously, mobile's
going directly to customers.
So these are the kinds of things
system administrators want
to be able to do.
So the moral here is not
thinking ahead is a sin.
Plan.
And this is where us as
Release Engineers can
work with our site reliability
engineers, and our field
service people, and so forth
on really thinking about this
and finding out, how our
customers using and installing
our software.
Some of these you can see it's
the admin in me coming out.
Thou shalt provide a detailed
log of what thou hath done.
Logging information is so
important to understanding
what is going on.
So when you do an installation,
when you do a dinstall,
there needs to be some
kind of logging mechanism.
That could be in
a log file, it can
be events that get sent out and
picked up by an event manager.
In related to
packaging, I want to be
able to unpack and
inspect the packages too.
I want to be able to install
without doing anything.
And the logs are so critical
for troubleshooting problems
because if you don't
know what's happened
in the sequence of
events, particularly
if have a very complicated
web based application
with lots of layers,
you need to be
able to understand the
sequence of events that
caused a particular
problem that happened.
Maybe you rolled out a
new application version
of your application
and something happened,
but it was something in the
infrastructure underneath that
changed at the same time
that caused the problem.
Unless you have
a picture of that
and there's logging
capabilities of some kind,
it's very, very difficult
to troubleshoot.
So canarying.
You need to have
canaries of some kind.
I think canarying-- I
ran across it most often
with cloud based applications,
web based application.
So everybody probably knows
this, but I put it up anyway.
The term came from
using domestic canaries
in coal mines,
because the canaries
would detect the carbon
monoxide build up
before the coal miners would.
And so they sacrificed the poor
canaries to save human lives.
So this canarying
refers to rolling out
to a small number of users.
And I think Chuck talked
about that in his talk,
about rolling out
to 2% of users.
Because this has been true of
all my years of working with
commercial software, customers
find problems we cannot find
in house, even if
your dog fooding.
And I think everybody dog foods.
Certainly in Google, where
I look at my phone and most
of my apps have bones
on them because they're
dog food version of that,
so my Android phone.
But customers are always going
to find corner cases and just
environments, just problems
we cannot reproduce.
So it's important to
do canary roll outs
to very, very small
number of users.
Also if you have all
the monitoring in place,
you can start detecting abnormal
changes in the patterns.
I used to work on our search
for an [INAUDIBLE] push.
And we did one job
at each data center.
We would roll out
across the whole world.
And we would start watching.
And then we would
bump the number up.
And we would start
watching the numbers
to see if there were problems.
And very often, we would detect
trends and problems early on,
could easily roll back.
Very small number of users
were affected or noticed
the problems.
But we could not do that
if we didn't canary,
because the risk
is just too high.
We don't want to push a new
version of Google search
everywhere at once.
That's just a bad idea.
Even thought we could, but
we're not going to do that.
This goes back to what I was
talking about at the beginning.
Our job is to accelerate
the path from Dev to DevOps.
We need to keep the
big picture in mind.
I think that is part
of our job and a value
add to our companies
is we really
need to be thinking about
stepping back constantly.
We have the fun job
where we get to go down
to the nuts and bolts.
We get to work with build
files, we get to write code,
but we also need to step back
and look at the big picture
and think about, OK, what
are our processes, what
are our best practices?
What can we do to
make things better?
I love the presentation
this morning about AWS.
Any analysis on cost savings?
That was great, and
that's the kind of thing
that we need to
be thinking about,
and we can use to actually
justify additional resources
to our management.
Because the bottom line is
it's all about money, right?
We like making the world's
information available,
which is Google's charter.
But we want to get paid for it.
Management is all about numbers.
I really enjoyed that
and took that away.
So keep in mind the big picture.
I think this venue is great
for doing that because we
get so focused on what we're
doing, and when you hear about.
Gee, they're solving the
same problem that we are.
And then you could also say,
oh I never thought about that.
It really helps us keep
the big picture in mind.
We would never run anything out
of our home directory right.
Because we're Release Engineers.
And we know the right
way to do this right?
We're going to package,
we're going to have our best
practices, we're
going to do it right.
No.
Everybody, I have Cron jobs
running out of stuff in my home
directory, I must admit.
Auditing and stuff I'm doing.
We can actually lead the way and
demonstrate, because we're all
probably involved with tool
development of some kind.
This is how you do
this and demonstrate
to the other organizations
that if some are resistant,
depends on how much clout you
have within your organization
to do things like get that
best practices in place.
And sometimes the
best way to do that is
from demonstration
and showing hey,
we went from release cycles
this long to release cycles
this long, with higher quality.
And so it's hard to
argue with the numbers.
Keep these commandments in line,
in mind apply them to yourself.
Before we get the questions,
I have a shameless plug.
It's a great year to
be a Release Engineer.
I am so excited about
everything that's going on.
this summit has been awesome.
Got to meet a lot of new people.
In June, Usenix is having
their very first summit
on Release Engineering.
I've been trying to talk and
do this in several years,
I've been telling
this is a hot topic
and they finally let me do it.
We got four times as
many submissions as this
we actually could except.
It's going to be
a great program.
in June in Philly.
On June 19th, the
day before, is going
to be a summit on
configuration management.
And I'm on that
program committee
and actually the
two programs are
going to really
work well together.
So it's a great
opportunity to meet again.
Then if that's not enough,
the first week in November,
I think it is in Seattle, we're
doing a co-located release
engineering summit with Lisa.
And I'm working with the
program chair of Lisa.
There's actually going to have
it, one day, same time as Lisa,
a summit, but there's also going
to be sessions during Lisa,
that are going to be
for Release Engineers.
There's going to be tutorials.
I'm really excited about that.
Usenix never seen a
response like we've
gotten for a first time summit.
So this is a hot area.
It's very exciting to be a
Release Engineer right now.
This is the first time,
I've unveiled this,
this is the June program.
I just finalized it
this week and you all
are the first ones
actually get to see it.
We've got a good cross section
of industry, types of talks,
I hope to see you all
there, or in Seattle.
I'm done.
Thank you.
Thank you Dinah.
AUDIENCE: Release
Engineers have to deal
with people on other teams and
manage lots of relationships.
Your commandments are mostly
about technical issues.
A really big part of being a
successful Release Engineer,
is managing relationships with
all of the other teams, who
are stakeholders in what
you're trying to release.
DINAH MCNUTT: I think
that [INAUDIBLE]
goes under the umbrella
of the big picture right.
That's part of the big picture.
AUDIENCE: Our Release Engineers
are also still engineers
and they have a tendency to
put their nose into their work
and not look up.
Calling this out explicitly
I think is pretty important.
DINAH MCNUTT: Good point.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
My question is, could you
provide some more clarification
around using package
management's.
Because I may not use
that to configure my
build machine of course,
but is there a way
that you would use it inside
the build process itself,
that's not dependent
on my Debian,
or that's not like RPM
or [INAUDIBLE] Dpacket.
DINAH MCNUTT: Well it's all
about taking bits and making
them available right.
So it really depends
on if you want
to use a package
as, we actually use
package as a interim storage
for builder artifacts in our
build system.
So because we have this highly
available very distributed
package manager
within Google, there
are build artifacts that we
will store in one of our NPMs,
just to make it available to
be used down the pipeline.
So depending on your
infrastructure, a package
repository, a yum repository
might be a good way
to make intermediate build
artifacts available possibly,
depending on what
your environment is.
So that's one example if
I understand your question
correctly of doing that.
AUDIENCE: So you're
actually suggesting
it's a good idea if their
local tests goes green,
but it needs to get in queue
for some larger integration
build or tasks, that they check
it into some sort of not code
repository but artifact
package management.
DINAH MCNUTT: Probably not,
because one of our best
practices is we have our
continuous integration
system, which does test
every time there's a commit,
but then when we
actually do a build,
we start with the
repository itself.
And we rerun those tests.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
really useful in the cases
where you do your on
your build systems.
On some platforms,
where you don't
want to necessarily
to grade source code,
you don't want to
put some source code
client to what there were
other pieces and piece of it.
So what you can do, you can
wrap your build framework
into packages and
deploy them with part
of the so what were
deployment, you
do when you deploy your
tools first on the platform.
So we do that for this team.
So we have some five
some based framework
and we wrap it into
packages and we deploy them
so we don't have,
we do version them
and everything so
don't get us wrong
but we don't have to
use source code clients
and they get them from
the source code repository
these bits and
pieces of framework
like we use for
the build system.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is about the commandment
you had about portability and
maintainability of build specs.
You said we should have portable
and maintainable build specs.
To some extent, are these
two qualities not opposed
to raise portability
you also have
to raise maintenance costs.
Maybe you could riff
a little on that.
DINAH MCNUTT: I think
what I had in mind
there was thinking about
how you architect them
and planning for
flexibility, configurability,
but being able to make a
single change and have it
propagate throughout
your whole system.
And so that's where I
was coming from on that.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Great commandments.
What are we doing to ensure that
we're basically training people
to know these commandments.
The biggest problem I have
is I cannot find people out
of school, or people
new engineers,
who like could know
those Ten Commandments.
I'm going to beat
into them one by one.
DINAH MCNUTT:
Here's my prediction
because, I went through this
with system administration.
I played an early role
in the development
of system administration as
a discipline A lot of that
and the reason we're seeing
curriculum for system
administration, was
actually the work
of sage, the Usenix
special interest group.
So I think organizations
like RelEng, like Usenix,
we already have an in with
some of the universities right.
I think we can
collaborate and come up
with the right curriculum.
Lots of opportunities for
people to give talks this year.
Oh I almost forgot.
There's the IEEE publication on
release engineering next year.
The deadline is August
4 first for that.
Also Usenix, has,
and by the way,
I got permission to do the
Usenix spiels ahead of time.
Usenix has an excellent
publication called login.
I have extra copies of
the April login up here.
In anticipation of
[INAUDIBLE], they
asked me to write an article
on what is release engineering,
because it's like
this elephant right.
I think the analogy I used
in the article in fact.
We're looking for
more submissions
on release engineering for this.
There's the IEEE
publication, which
I plan on submitting
something for.
So I think there's going to
be lots of opportunities.
We're going to see
possibly good standards.
I've been around
standards for a long time.
I think you're here.
I think this is the start of it.
FOUTSE KHOMH: Yeah just to build
a bit of that, now University
actually we have a cost that
we just started [INAUDIBLE]
on Release Engineering.
And in July, coming July we have
a mini Windows summer school
that we'll be doing
three days school
on release engineering stuff.
I think we're pushing
in that direction.
DINAH MCNUTT: I think we need
to have some camps at Google.
I think it'd be a great idea.
AUDIENCE: If we're all on
the hook for recruiting.
[INAUDIBLE] It is
on all of us right.
And I have to go for
all of our companies,
I'm sure we're all on the
hook for recruiting right.
So they drag me out to
campuses, but I have a deck
that I've made for college
campuses like you said,
what is release engineering,
to at least open their minds
in their junior and
senior years that this
is a track that's available.
So I think it's up to us when
we go on our recruiting trips
to make sure we have a deck
or something we can give
the 20 minute pitch, that
gets them excited about it.
DINAH MCNUTT: I
don't think anything
I said today was earth
shattering to this audience.
I went over to Netflix and did
a dry run earlier this week
and it was really great because
the person I was giving it to
was like, oh yeah
that's a good one.
I was able to get
his first reaction.
And it's like sometimes
just seeing it all at once
and it's like, well yeah
doesn't everybody do this.
And it's like well
no, some people
haven't thought about
some of the points.
AUDIENCE: So an
observation actually,
I think the ideas that you
all throughout our great,
but the open source community
has been actually really
driving this cadence
based release process.
We heard from Mozilla earlier
and Gnome and one of the ways
that Google has
been contributing
to this problem is trying to
get students in universities
involved in the open source
community really early.
With the Google Summer
of Code program,
which has some hundreds of
participants every year.
So the more that
students in university
are plugged in to
release processes early,
I think is a great
opportunity for students
to learn about release
practices and best practices.
MALE SPEAKER: Well with that,
let's give a hand to Dinah.